[Musique]
je crois que nous pourrions passer
maintenant à peine deux jours le film de
bunuel et qui a n'a pas été sélectionné
pour kansas à nous en avons parlé
l'autre jour et ce film de bunuel et
tiré d'un roman de joseph kessel il est
interprété par catherine deneuve a été
réalisée en france est un film français
de bunuel sur un scénario adapté par
jean paul carrière qui est qu adapteur
aussi du journal d'une femme de chambre
avec le même but elle mais aussi de viva
maria avec louis malle ce qui prouve
qu'il touche à beaucoup de choses du
voleur aussi de tati wifi alors on peut
peut-être donner les couleurs tout de
suite pour belle de jour marque à bruges
c'est un roman feuilleton l'illustré
michel briand patrick inconditionnels
inconditionnellement pour avant de
l'avoir vu et après aussi énormément
pour et charensol énormément contre le
roman énormément pour le film patrick
ans dont vous approuvez vous allez vous
rejoindre pour une situation difficile
oui commencé alors non d'abord il ya un
point qui me chagrine toujours c'est que
je n'aime pas à parler tout premier film
de bunuel les film de bunuel de français
je crois que le domaine espagnol domaine
mexicain convient beaucoup mieux bunuel
que le domaine français
je crois d'abord aussi que une certaine
distance dans le temps lui convient
également et que lorsqu'il fait des
films contemporains brusquement on censé
frime date curieusement quand ils sont
contemporains lorsqu'ils sont d'un autre
temps quand ils ont 5 ans qui sont
cinquante ans en arrière si vous voulez
à ce moment là ils sont très modernes
mais quand ils sont quand il se passe
aujourd'hui il cesse d'être moderne et
j'ai trouvé dans belle de nuit
exactement l'univers de mirebeau on me
dira bon mirebeau c'est très bien c'est
les mêmes systèmes de provocation de
clins d'oeil ça ne me concerne
absolument pas je trouve c'est un film
tout à fait date et d'un vieux monsieur
tout ce qui est à vous sur ajouté quel
domaine se réalise par exemple on sent
que c'est sûr ajouter ya une histoire et
un feuilleton histoire feuilletonesque
abominable qui est celle de kessel que
tous très très mauvaise histoire est un
très mauvais rôle
hangar tout à fait est là dessus par
moments on nous passe une deux trois
quatre séquence surréaliste qui sont
complètement plaqué sur ce film qui ne
correspondent absolument pas à ce film
et à l'histoire racontée et là on a une
sorte d'alibi onu elle joue quand il
fait des films en france sur cet alibi
c'était la même chose pour joindre une
femme de chambre j'avoue pour ma part je
ne marche pas du tout finie crois pas
une seule seconde je trouve qu'on est
toujours d'un aveuglement et d'une
complaisance à l'égard de lunel je crois
qu'il faudra y revenir un jour en fayat
à l'égard de lui une sorte de critique
terroriste dès qu'on parle de bunuel qui
fait qu'on ne peut plus rien dire contre
lui au brillant je suis assez mauvais
juge pour ce film parce que là je
m'excuse mais hélas je ne connais pas
les maisons de rendez vous je les
fréquente pas alors je sais pas si ça se
passe comme ça
mais enfin lorsque vous dites marque à
bruz c'est un mauvais roman nous savons
que c'est un mauvais roman mais moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un film vous
dites il ya des séquences surréaliste
je ne trouve pas qu'il ya des séquences
sur elle et je trouve c'est un film
kenny uniquement un film onirique un
film poétique
pour moi c'est la songerie l'espèce de
rêve d'une petite bourgeoise et 1967 qui
a acheté justement dans une bibliothèque
de gares romandes kessel les sept jeunes
femmes et frustrée elle s'imagine ce que
seraient les perversions c'est les
perversions et perversions les plus
noires à travers ce roman totalement
démodé de 1930 et et moi ce qui me
touche c'est justement cette espèce de
chamboulement entre les époques ou
encens et il était très facile de jouer
la carte 1930
pourquoi ne l'ont ils pas fait beaucoup
de bunuel ne l'at il pas fait c'est que
ça appartient au domaine du rêve que
perpétuellement c'est un rêve du récit
n'a pas traité les séquences oniriques
dans un style surréaliste très
volontairement pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
décalage et tout le film est un rêve
tout le film est une espèce de
d'imagination pour différentes de ces
petites jeunes femmes il sait rien il
s'est rien passé
son mari elle n'a jamais été dans les
maisons de rendez vous
son mari n'a jamais été assassiné par
deux n'a jamais été va lever risée par
ce personnage qui est extrêmement
caricaturale volontairement d'une espèce
c'est un fantasme c'est pour ça que
j'aime le film merci aux brillants ses
marques a brûlé au troisième degré moi
je vous avoue que quand tu les vues avec
une salle populaire pour les gens
marchent au premier degré ne cherche pas
cette explication et d'où certains
bunuel à cette explication ce n'est pas
vous qui l'a donnée et de toute façon en
quoi ce rêve est intéressante cette
femme cette famille sans aucun intérêt
absolument pas vous demandez encore
moins d'une certaine manière ce n est
même pas un film de contestation en
aucune façon l'univers de l'hexagone on
est quand même poêle oui mais c'est
absolument mardor michelle martin je
crois qu'un film justement sur le rêve
et cette interprétation de briand et
passionnante même si elle est fausse ça
n'a aucune importance
un film sur le rêve est toujours positif
dans la mesure où le rêve est plutôt
supérieurs à la vie et cette femme se
réalise dans le rêve alors qu'elle se
réalise disons concrètement sexuellement
comme les spectateurs l'entendent au
premier degré ou d'une manière poétique
comme briand vous le suggérez de toute
façon il est très important que ce rêve
existe et qui prolifèrent dans toutes
les directions
avec
toutes les perfections perversion
possibles et imaginables inspiré par la
lecture tantôt de kessel et en tout du
marquis de sade mélanger ce que disait
marc abri tout à l'heure contre
l'anecdote de kessel justement contre le
roman c'est favorable à bunuel dans la
mesure où pour un vrai surréaliste le
roman n'existe pas il faut être abject
dizaines de photos je crois pour 100 g à
écrire un roman
donc le roman et rambo est d'accord je
donc le roman étant par principe abjecte
ce n'est qu'un argument une base pour
faire proliférer le rêve dessus et ce
qui est très beau c'est que ce n'est pas
le chien andalou c'est à dire que rien
ne s'avoue dans ce film comme l'oeuvre
de l'imagination mais au contraire c'est
la vie réelle alors vous voyez les gens
entrer au george st il croit voir un
mail au lasso la cua et ils sont en
plein dans le rêve de quelqu'un qui est
bunuel ou qui catherine deneuve on ne
sait pas trop et ils en sortent
absolument abasourdi
maintenant c'est peut-être pour de
mauvaises raisons ils vont voir aussi
blu ray pour de très mauvaises raisons
merci michel marder georges charensol
pour moi belle de jour est exactement
précisément le contraire de blow up
oui d'emblée rappelé je disais tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait à mon sens deux
films qui ne coïncident absolument pas
je vois le film ambiguë elle à antonioni
et je vois à le reportage sur un monde
extrêmement superficielle extrêmement
voyant à londres tout au contraire dans
belle de jour je vois une intégration
extraordinairement habile et d'une très
grande sincérité d'un thème différent
que benny elle commence par traité d'une
façon disons le assez banal assez
réaliste bien que dès le début il y ait
cette promenade en calèche qui déjà nous
alerte et puis peu à peu tout en nous
racontant une histoire qui n'est pas de
lui il arrive à y faire entrer ses
propres fantômes et à ce moment-là à moi
il me passionne comme à partir du moment
où ça décolle et où ce n'est plus du
kessel est celui d'une bunuel
je trouve ça tout à fait extraordinaire
et il est certain que lorsqu'il crée ces
deux personnages d'hippolyte et de
marcel qui sont vraiment des personnages
denis réalisme absolument totale il est
absolument impensable que ces deux
garçons puissent faire sur doc puisse se
balader dans les rues dans ses tenues
incroyables et c'est à partir de ce
moment là moi je marche complètement et
je retrouve le grand duel non pas du
tout le bunuel mexicain où le bus lui
elle de ses précédents films français
qui sont en effet très discutable mais
j'y retrouve le grand bunuel de
viridiana legrand bunuel espagnol qui
pour moi a est en effet un très grand
homme l'oeuvre de bunuel n'est pas du
tout un bloc comme l'était la révolution
française pour clemenceau il faut faire
un choix
mais il y a quelques film de bunuel
l'ange exterminateur par exemple bas
tout de même chapeau merci georges
charensol de la soul arrêtiez
moitié-moitié oui j'écoute et leurs
chars ans à la raison il ya de grands
moments de dans le style de bunuel mai
enfin le film dans son ensemble quand
même si on admet l'hypothèse astucieuse
du musée le brillant oui à ce moment là
en tant que rêve total mais sinon je
sais pas ça me l'indiquer tout moment ce
côté onirique
on passe à tout moment sur les séquences
oniriques et qui sont traités sur un
temps réel à centrer mais alors je sois
je croise un délit est oui mais
volontairement pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
réclamations 3 votre coin des petits
qu'un second lieu il ya un élément que
nous oublions c'est un film d'amour
c'est vraiment être cette fille est
prodigieusement amoureuse de son mari et
en même temps et le souffle
prodigieusement de ne pas être accordés
sur un plan physique avec lui et je
trouve c'est un problème de temps qui
déchire on doit cesser
quand on dit que c'est superficiel comme
blow up suis pas du tout d'accord
là c'est un problème important du monde
bon alors moi je fabrique rambo d'abord
ce que j'aimerais que l'on m'explique
c'est quand on dit ce film est d'un peu
surréaliste par ci se réalise par la
jemmerais je suis pas c'est pas la sauce
tomate surréaliste c'est pas un
ingrédient
c'est une façon de voir les choses si
vous l'avez pas rester dehors allez vous
coucher je ne sais pas
et puis deuxièmement moi je vous dire
comment je vois ce film ça me fait
penser à un tableau de magritte qui
s'appelle le jour et la nuit
vous avez une rue de nu de deux nuls
éclairé de lampadaires ça est au dessus
vous avez le ciel est un ciel de 2010
vous regardez ce tableau fait
actuellement pas attention mais qu'est
ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire ce tableau
et vous rendez pas compte qu'il ya dans
le même tableau il ya le jour et la nuit
mais moi j'ai causé quand j'ai vu le
film devenu l on sait absolument pas où
est le jour et voient la nuit s'il
voulait un petit peu pédant excusez moi
non mais ça me paraît une bonne
explication effectivement % très bien se
voulait plus en plus simple pour moi de
lui nu est un peu l'auberge espagnole
dire que
j'ai été déformés par mauvaise lecture
n'est ce pas beaucoup plus de choses oui
il est certain que quand on va voir un
film en se disant à priori bunuel j'aime
beaucoup on y met même beaucoup de
choses même si on n'est pas sur les mais
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas tous un peu
inquiet quand même de voir bunuel fait
des films en france utilisent jean paul
carrière sur votre carrière
me paraître justement vous dites on est
surréaliste on ne met pas fin à gré dian
il pas réutiliser le surréalisme d'une
manière gym comme d'assos thomas non ils
l'utilisent pas regarder parce que le
voleur darien moi je le lis de darien
s'est mis livre de chevet je lis peu
près tous les deux mois je relis de
voleurs darien et trois mois on la
sortie du film j'étais vraiment effrayé
de voir louis malle faire ça j'hésitais
quand même je suis allé vraiment dans de
très mauvaises conditions
et puis je trouvais c'était la meilleure
façon de rendre le livre de darien non
je pense mais je ne cherche pas être
objectif du tout je ne cherche jamais le
nom mais le terrorisme et critique même
ne faut pas en abuser
je le fais ce que je dis ce que je pense
tout de même carrière
un peu un peu en dehors de l'univers du
duel
il s'agit pas de savoir si les
surréalisme non mais on lui doit sans
doute quelques règles du jeu suit
quelques répliques qui sentent de très
loin leur michel audiard par exemple
lorsqu'un japonais entrent dans la
maison de rendez vous est présente à la
tenancière une carte et le lit sur la
carte credit car des chats club et
l'audi no non ici on paie enfants et en
billets toute la salle rim c'est une
réplique qui est bonne avec gabin et
audiard elle est assez indigne de bunuel
et il y en a cinq ou six de ce genre on
risque dans la salle d'audience sur ce
bel deux jours
oui je devrais venir à la rescousse de
monsieur marc à bruz parce que je suis
tout à fait de son avis je n'ai rien
retrouvé du duel que j'aime c'est à dire
du menu l2 viridiana et de l'ange
experts exterminateur j'ai trouvé un
film qui est un mauvais feuilleton gars
aussi et puis temps en temps je me suis
j'avais le sentiment que bunuel se
souvenait qu'il était bunuel
alors il nous plaque une séquence et ils
adorent sign communiante après nous
avoir montré des respectueuse et puis
tout d'un coup ils nous plaque une
séquence avec moby avec une petite fille
et est un monsieur qui la caresse enfin
tout d'un coup il se souvient qu'il est
bunuel et le reste du temps c'est un
mélo insupportable moi je ne suis pas du
tout sensibles au drame de cette fille
ça ne m'intéresse vraiment pas du tout
en ce sens pas du tout concerné j'étais
très triste de voir ce que ce que buñuel
et est devenu en france
vraiment je trouve que les films
français sont devenus elle ne lui
ressemble pas du tout bref le sud merci
d'une barque à bruay ravi de votre
soutien
j'aurais quand même posé une dernière
question c'est que je crois que c'est
michel delahaye qui me disait l'autre
jour que
il fallait ne faudrait jamais donné sur
l'opinion sur ce film car la censure
avait fait douze coupure alors ça je ne
sais pas si noir des coupures quand même
qu'ils sont assez importantes dans la
mesure où je défie qui que ce soit de
comprendre la scène du du coréen ou
l'asiatique qui vient avec ces espèces
de petites boîtes questionnant la petite
boîte
tout le monde a l'air effrayé pia jamais
l'explication et je moi je connais la
coupure je peux pas dire tellement en
france
[Rires]
[Musique]